okay it's pretty interesting so thanks
everyone for coming so I'll be telling
you about watermarking and traded
tracing for pseudo-random functions and
much of this work is joined with Irish
up Sam
and Brent and for it's the end of this
talk I'll talk more about how we
instantiate a lot of the underlying
building blocks from lattice based
assumptions so when we get there I'll
introduce the construction step so
listen okay so let's begin by recalling
a notion of software watermarking as has
been defined in the literature so far so
in a software watermarking scheme the
goal is as follows we have a piece of
program we have a piece of code or a
software and our goal is to embed some
mark within this program in such a way
that the mark program still behaves
essentially the same as the original
program so I can embed a string let's
say a serial number a username a the
owner's name within a piece of software
such that the resulting code still
operates exactly as before but with the
guarantee that if somebody comes along
with a watermark version of the code and
tries and removed that mark from the
program that will destroy the
functionality of the program so somehow
the mark is fundamentally tied to the
operation of the software itself so the
canonical applications that has been
proposed for studying and realizing
software watermarking it's about things
like proving the ownership of the
software if I own the software I can
embed my name or some ID within it so
that if somebody steals my software and
uses it for unauthorized purposes there
will be some way of identifying and that
that software indeed belongs to me other
settings where this has been used in is
in protecting against unauthorized
redistribution of software is very
conceptually similar to the setting of
trader tracing which I will also discuss
later on in this talk so just to make
sure that we're on the same page
regarding what a software watermarking
scheme does it's usually parametrized by
two main algorithms there's a marking
algorithm that first takes as
description a program and in this talk
we're going to model programs as Olien
circles so it takes as the description a
boolean circuit C and
takes instant-message em this will be
called a mark and it outputs a marked
circuit C prime and there's also an
extraction algorithm that takes as
description a marked circuit and eyes
are outputs bot which indicates that the
circuit or program is unmarked or it
recovers the corresponding message so
syntactically basically there's a mark
algorithm that embeds a mark inside a
program and it is an extraction
algorithm that takes the program as
input and extracts the actual mark we
can define many different notions
sometimes you can have the extraction
algorithm just have blackbox access to C
prime in other cases you can actually
have it take in the code of C prime like
here we'll just look at that is very
simple schematic for now so now let me
define the prevailing definitions for a
watermarking scheme so the primary
notion is this notion of correctness
which basically says that if I embed a
mark within the program the resulting
program should behave essentially the
same as the original program so one
might ask we know why don't we require
that the marked version of the program
became identically as the original one
and mainly we don't change the behavior
the input-output behavior of the program
well the reason we don't do that is
because assuming the existence of
indistinguishability obfuscation perfect
functionality preserving watermarking is
impossible and so the resulting works on
studying watermarking for software has
focused on a relaxed notion of
functionality preserving which just says
that the marked version of the program
agree was the original one almost
everywhere so for instance if the domain
is soup is super polynomial size then
the points on which the two programs the
first should be a negligible fraction of
the domain itself okay so the intuitive
notion is that i am betting mark in the
program the resulting program still
behaves roughly the same as the original
one and the second requirement for a
watermarking scheme it's basically
saying that the mark should somehow be
linked to the functionality of the
program itself mainly an adversary an
efficient adversary that has access to a
mark program is not able to produce
new program the Scala seastar here such
that C star and the marked program agree
almost everywhere so namely is still
functionality preserving on the domain
of the program and yet the extraction
algorithm fails to extract the original
watermark so in particular if an
adversary is able to reproduce the
functionality of the program the
reproduced program must also contain the
watermark if the adversary manages to
remove the watermark from the program
you must also destroy the functionality
and this seems like a very natural
notion of watermarking namely if i can
remove the mark i must destroy the thing
that I was protecting in the first place
and here I want to emphasize that this
is actually a fairly flexible adversary
the adversary is allowed to see the code
the description of the market program
itself and it has complete flexibility
in crafting his new programs d-star
right so when I talked about it earlier
when I said that the mark extraction
algorithm may have either access to the
code or an Oracle access to the program
when we talk about it from the
perspective of the adversary the
adversary is given a complete
description of the code and even then it
should be hard for the adversary to
remove the watermark from the program
itself ok so this is a fairly powerful
adversary the only restriction on the
adversary is that it has to be efficient
so computationally bound it
so having such a fairly strong
adversarial model it turns out that this
notion is only achievable for certain
classes of functionalities and in
particular cost limit all in their paper
they showed that this notion gives only
possible for functionalities that are
not learn about this is not very
surprising simply because if you have a
efficient algorithm that can learn the
description of a function just give an
Oracle access to it well they can take
the marked version of the program and
learn the original unmarked version and
that immediately gives you an efficient
mechanism to remove the watermark from a
marker program so as a result of this
impossibility result much of the work on
software watermarking has actually
focused on the class of programs that
not efficiently learn a ball from a
cryptographic perspective a natural
class is the class of cryptographic
functions so as a result of this much of
the work software watermarking with
these strong formal security guarantees
has focused on studying watermarking
cryptographic functionalities such as
pseudo-random functions or publicly
encryption digital signatures and so on
and that will also be the focus of this
work and in particular we're going to
focus on a symmetric setting on a secret
key setting where we are watermarking
pseudo-random functions so when I say we
watermark a pseudo-random function what
I mean is be the function the program
has hardwired and sided a key for a
pseudo-random function and it takes as
an input and it basically computes the
output of the PRF evaluated on that
point and the reason that pseudo-random
functions are studied is because
essentially they are the workhorses of
symmetric cryptography once we know how
the watermark a pseudo-random function
if you now want to say what are more
other kinds of symmetric primitives like
the signing algorithm for a message
authentication code the decryption
algorithm for a secret key encryption
scheme once you have it ERF it
immediately implies one remarkable
notions of these higher level primitives
at least that's not what we believe this
is why we focus or there has been a lot
of work focusing on watermarking these
types of functions okay so the first
thing I want to do in this talk and an
is to actually start revisiting this
definition of watermarking so this is
see we have started byte out by talking
about watermarking general programs now
we have specialized that the
watermarking pseudo-random functions and
the question is how suitable or does
these kinds of prevailing security
notions that we defined which seem very
natural right now how well do they
actually capture the security notion
that we might want from a software
watermarking scheme so let's recall this
definition of unremovable icky which
basically in the setting of watermarking
pseudo-random functions so a special
class of functionalities it says that
and nobody is able so nor no efficient
adversary
is able to replicate the behavior of my
pseudo-random function and yet does
remove the watermark right so if the
adversary produces a program that can
compute or evaluate the pseudo-random
functionality that program if it agrees
with the original one most of the points
it has to contain the water merge but
what if we consider an adversary that
instead of computing and constructing a
program that outputs the entirety of the
PRF output it is there just outputs
let's say in the first quarter of the
bits of the PRF right so here I've
constructed a new program let me see if
I can get a pointer here we have a new
program that computes the output of the
PRF but instead of outputting all of the
bits of the PRF we have a program that
outputs the first n over four bits where
n over four where n is the output length
of the pseudo-random function so we
consider this new program well this new
program is not functionality preserving
anymore right
it does not agree with the original
function on any point right now every
single point in the domain of the
original function it disagrees and yet
at the same time this new program still
captures a lot of important information
about the original function however the
existing definitions for software
watermarking says nothing about such an
adversary it can well be the case that
our such a program
the watermark is not preserved anymore
and yet from conceptual perspective such
a program still carries a lot of
information about the original program
is this ever problematic right so
basically we have an adversary circuit
that doesn't provide functionality we
have no guarantees under this definition
of whether the watermark is preserved in
this new program on the right or not ok
so does this actually matric right do we
actually want a definition to actually
capture these kinds of settings well it
turns out that in many natural scenarios
where we might want a watermark the
pseudo-random function or one watermarks
such cryptographic functionalities this
could be problematic so let's consider a
standard application that has been
proposed for watermarking pseudo-random
functions one thing is we want to pro
tapped against the unauthorized
redistribution of decryption keys now
this is also a classic trader tracing
scenario we want to issue many different
PRF keys to each user we embed their ID
with the meteor s key if they now happen
to try and leak their p RS t then we
would be able to trace which he was
compromised or which key was leaked so
suppose now that we're using a PRF based
encryption scheme so let's say take your
PRF evaluating counter mode this gives
you your standard CPA secure encryption
scheme and we're using it to encrypt
let's say digital media like images or
video content this is something that
what you might see so now suppose that
an adversary comes along they have a
marked version of some decryption device
for some decryption key and they create
a new program that essentially outputs
their pseudo-random function value but
only preserves the first and over four
bits
it only outputs the first quarter of the
bits of the PRF if I have access to such
a program I can use it to try and
partially be crypt this encrypted image
and if you run it you get what's look
what's visualized on the right here so
here we're not doing any kind of fancy
image processing we're just saying that
if we don't know what the output value
of the PRF is on a particular bit we'll
just say that it's zero otherwise we
will use the decrypted value you use
this key to try and decrypt this
encrypted image and lo and behold you
actually recover a lot of information
about the underlying encrypted message
so this should not be very surprising if
we're leaking half let's say a quarter
of the bits of the PRF we're leaking a
quarter of that of the any message that
we are encrypting and this essentially
says or hopefully showcases that in some
sense a program such as the one I'm
showing here is actually good enough in
most settings right this doesn't
necessarily preserve the exact
input-output behavior of the
pseudo-random function but it does it
works well enough to break the security
of any application it depends on a
pseudo randomness of the PRF right and
so an adversary that produces such a
program that can basically break
security of your application
ideally if we're using watermarking as a
way to protect against this kind of
behavior this program should still
contain the watermark so the main
takeaway I want to hook I hope that this
example illustrates is that four
building blocks like pseudo-random
functions for cryptographic
functionalities and even for general
software tying the security requirement
of a watermarking scheme to having to
print had requiring that the adversary
succeed only by preserving the exact
input-output behavior seems like too
strong of a con restriction on the
adversaries ability to try and defeat
the scheme there are many natural
scenarios not maybe not just limited to
cryptographic ones here's an extra
program is there a pole where the
adversary is able to construct the
program that still preserves enough
information about the original program
and yet may not preserve the exactly
input-output behavior and fast will not
be captured by existing watermarking
security definitions so in a particular
case of TRS I argue that exact
functionality preserving requirements
does not seem like a strong enough
security notion if the adversary is able
to break the primitive that relies
that's a pseudo randomness then that
watermark should in principle be
preserved and unfortunately we take a
look at the existing watermarking
constructions that has been proposed in
the setting of pseudo-random functions
and they actually do not are not robust
against these kinds of adversaries
mainly an adversary that just outputs
the first n over four bits of the
pseudo-random function all of these
existing schemes will fail to actually
reach extract the embedded message
within the water markable PRF and so if
we try and use these water multiple key
RS as a building block in systems that
are relying on water marking for some
kind of protection those schemes would
not be robust against these classes of
attacks okay so any questions regarding
the definitions or the shortcomings of
the existing definitions next I will say
how we propose to address these kinds of
shortcomings and in doing so introduce a
new notion that tries to capture and
define a much
stronger security notion okay all right
so in this work we propose a notion that
tries and addresses many of the
limitations and challenges that we
perceive any existing definitions or
software watermarking in a particular
for the notion for the setting of
watermarking pseudo-random functions
right so the way that we're going to
approach this is we're going to first
take a step back right and think about
what does it mean for what are we trying
to protect when you are trying to
watermark a pseudo-random function well
a pseudo-random function is useful
because it's input-output behavior it's
indistinguishable from a random one
right the security requirement of a
pseudo-random function is pseudo
randomness mainly that it is
indistinguishable from a truly random
function so from a conceptual
perspective it seems like if we want to
protect a pseudo-random function or a
program that implements a PRF well we
want to protect this the pseudo
randomness property itself namely if an
adversary is able to produce a program
we don't care what the program does
but if the program allows us or gives us
a distinguishing advantage of the P for
the PRF against the truly random
function and this program potentially
can break the security of any scheme
that relies on the PRF and therefore
this program is useful and if the
program is useful then it should
preserve the watermark so an informal
way of viewing our news tracing or a new
security definition is that if the
adversary produces a program that helps
it distinguish the outputs of the PRF
from a truly random function then that
program must contain the watermark right
so of course this captures the existing
watermarking notions where the
watermarking security notion says if the
adversary produces a program that
replicates the exact input-output
behavior of the PRF almost everywhere it
must contain a watermark here we say
well forget about preserving the
input-output behavior everywhere just
help me distinguish if you can help me
distinguish we say the program is marked
so let's dive into this definition a
little more closely and see how we can
actually formalize it so this is the
intuition of these
in why we would take this a perspective
in trying to address some of the
shortcomings of existing water marketing
definitions this is of course very very
similar and exact the direct analog of
trader tracing but specialized to the
domain of pseudo-random functions so I'm
not going to go into details here I
think reshef gave a talk at the last
lattice workshop on trader tracing so
I'll just recall that definition or the
notion there so in a classic setting of
trainer tracing we'll find a protect
decription keys and essentially the
security definition there says and if
you have a program that is able to
distinguish ciphertext encryptions of
two different messages then the tracing
algorithm will successively
recover the identity or the mark from
that particular program here we're doing
the same thing except instead of looking
at a decryption algorithm we're looking
at a pseudo-random function and so we're
trying to specialize that kind of trader
tracing definition and to the setting of
pseudo-random functions mainly now if we
have a program that can help us
distinguish then that program should
contain and preserve the watermark so
let's take a look at trying to formalize
this new kind of tracing definition
again our initial motivation is that if
the adversary who's given a march
version of the circuit produces a new
circuit that can distinguish that should
preserve the original mark so the way
that is what this would look like is
well what this distinguisher circuit
that the adversary produces is going to
play the distinguishing game for the
pseudo-random function what is the
distinguishing game well basically there
are two different worlds the
distinguisher can make chosen message
queries so it can choose an input X and
in a pseudo random world against the PRF
evaluation at X in a truly random world
it gets a random function evaluated at X
and the goal of the distinguisher is to
figure out which one of these worlds is
living it now this might seem like a
very natural notion it turns out that
this is actually going to be somewhat
problematic to achieve because if you
think about it the adversary here has a
program that can evaluate the PRF almost
everywhere
right so what the adversary can do is
your sample random domain element X
start here and just hard code C with a
single input output of the PRF right it
just Arcos the input X star and the
actual value of the PRF at X star which
the adversary could have computed given
its own program and this is the only
thing that seed us C just has one
hardwired point in the PRF and this this
this circuit right here I claim can have
distinguishing advantage that's
negligibly close to one in the PRF game
namely this C just queries on X star and
it checks at the output it gets from the
Oracle on either the pseudo-random case
or the truly random case is equal to the
actual value of the PRF right so this
says that if we have a strong PRF
distinguisher if the PRF distinguisher
is allowed to make adaptive queries and
compare it against some let's say set of
values that it knows it can always break
pseudo randomness but of course if we
only have one single point of the PRF
one single input output of C doesn't
really have that much information about
the structure or the properties of the
PRF it seems very very difficult if not
impossible to be able to trace such a
circuit see it seems very difficult to
actually be able to extract an
identifier so somehow this definition is
too strong so we have to relax it a
little bit and the wait a week the
relaxation that we consider here is that
instead of allowing the circusy to make
adaptive queries of is choosing to
either the pseudo random Oracle or in a
truly random Oracle we instead allow the
advert we instead allow the circusy only
access to the PRF evaluation and random
points right so instead of allowing C or
the distinguisher that the adversary
chooses to select the points adaptively
those points are sample uniformly at
random and now i need to distinguish
sure used to be able to distinguish the
PRF evaluations at random points versus
rep outputs of a random function and of
course this is exactly the definition of
weak pseudo randomness so rather than
allow requiring that the this thing we
share breaks strong pseudo randomness
it seems very difficult to have a
realizable definition here we instead
relax it and say that if the adversary
produces a new circuit see that suffice
us to break weak pseudo randomness of
the PRF mainly it has enough information
about the global structure of the PRF
basically be a evaluations or the input
alpha behavior of the PRF on a
significant fraction of the domain then
that distinguisher must can be traced
mainly we can actually extract the mark
auric from the circuit itself and here
I'll mention that the distinguisher that
the adversary produces its allowed to
see arbitrarily many input-output pairs
so you can view it as the distinguisher
has access to an Oracle and every time
it queries the Oracle and the Oracle
will sample an input and either give the
output of the pseudo-random function or
the output of a truly random function so
this is the tracing definition that
we're going to work with basically if we
have a distinguisher that can break weak
pseudo randomness of the PRF then that
distinguisher is good and if it's good
that means that extraction algorithm the
mark extraction or tracing algorithm
will be able to recover the watermark
from the program itself
okay so let's define everything more
precisely so we can reason about the
properties and actually construct this
primitive so at a syntactic level a
traceable PRF consists of the following
algorithms there's a set up algorithm a
sample is the master secretly this is
the secret key for the PRF as well as a
tracing G and we can consider multiple
notions we can consider the case where
the tracing key is a public key or cases
where the tracing key is secret I'll say
a few more words about the constructions
and these two different regimes later on
then there's a marking algorithm that
here we'll call degeneration that
basically takes the PRF key it takes in
an ID and an output say secret key that
has the ID embedded inside it okay so
this is essentially the ID is that it's
the analogue of the mark in that
watermarking see then there's an
evaluation over some pics in the secret
key takes in the domain element
produces a range element here I'm going
to overload this evaluation algorithm
for simplicity the evaluation algorithm
contacted actual PRF
or 84 in a particular identity and
finally we have a tracing algorithm that
takes in a tracing key and it only has
Oracle access to the decoders here and
it produces a subset of identities that
could have been compromised or that were
used to generate actually so this is the
essentially in the analog of the
extraction algorithm so let me mention
one caveat of the definition that we're
proposing here here we're saying that
the tracing he is actually sampled in
conjunction with the key for the
pseudo-random function and this is kind
of implicit or somewhat they are
necessary for this kind of definition
because the tracing algorithms here in
order to use this decoder right or I'm
sorry in order to use this distinguisher
it needs to be able to sample
input-output pairs of the PRF right so
essentially tracing algorithm has to
know some information about the master
PRF G so there this is one conceptual
distinction with the notion of
watermarking in a sense that the tracing
Hughes here has to be completely tied to
the PRF G and what I'm working this is
not necessary potentially but as a
result you end up being able to only
achieve a much weaker notion of security
and if the tracing she doesn't know
anything about the PRF key well it's not
going to be able to use this
distinguisher area and watermarking we
say that well because the adversary's
program it is useful it has to preserve
the input-output behavior so essentially
the adversary is a useful adversary
program actually gives you that
information about the PRF G yeah we only
have a distinguisher distinguisher may
not give you actual information about
the PRF evaluations right it may not
allow you to actually evaluate the PRF
it can only distinguish evaluations from
random or not so this is actually
essential to realizing I knew that much
stronger a security notion that
addresses many of the shortcomings with
the existing definitions okay so what
are the main properties we care about
with the traceable pseudo-random
function well all of these are the exact
analogs of the definitions we solve for
watermarking so first is correctness
which basically says that the Marc key
and the unmarked key should agree almost
everywhere so here we have evaluation
using that
unmarked keys for the master key RS key
here we have the evaluation using a
markup see and they should agree on all
but a negligible fraction of the domain
a begin considers from their notions of
correctness for instance that these
points should be hard to find for this
talk I'll just focus on this weaker
notion where basically almost all of the
points in the domain the mark key and
the unmarked key will agree of course we
want pseudo randomness which says that
the evaluation algorithm using the
master PRF key should be pseudo-random
here we can again consider multiple
notions we can say it doesn't have to be
weak pseudo-random were a strong
pseudo-random all of these distinctions
are not really essential for this talk
so I'll just work with the simpler
definition and just say the evaluation
algorithm should implement a
pseudo-random function and finally we
have the analog of on removability which
we capture by this tracing game so the
tracing game is going to be a game
played between an adversary and a
challenger adversary here Challenger
here for simplicity once again I'll just
describe the single key setting where we
assume that the adversary only sees a
single mark key so the game then
proceeds as follows the adversary begins
by choosing an identity that it wants to
get a mark key for and the Challenger
will reply by marking the key with the
chosen identity and after this the
adversary's goal is to output a
distinguisher and we basically want to
require and if the distinguisher is able
to break the weak pseudo randomness of
the evaluation algorithm with some
noticeable advantage epsilon then a
tracing algorithm will output this
identity with probability again that's
very close to epsilon so namely given a
marked program for an identity of the
adversaries choosing the adversary
cannot produce a distinguisher that is
effective and yet does not contain the
mark and once again we can also consider
stronger notions where we give the
adversary Oracle access to say the PRF
evaluation and other Oracle's but again
I'm just going to focus on a minimal
definition nesto gives us something very
interesting so for simplicity in this
talk I'll just work with this definition
here well we're not going to worry about
it
alarm calls at the address room they
have access to in a paper we provide the
definition in its full generality okay
so what let me just first mention that
once we define a traceable pseudo-random
function in this way as a sort of a
showcase that this definition is
actually useful where it gives us
meaningful implications it actually
directly implies the trader tracing
notions for standard symmetric
primitives so for instance consider our
favorite PRF based encryption scheme
where basically you stand for months you
evaluate the PRF under nonce and use
that the blind a message well if we
instantiate this PRF right here with a
PRF to satisfies this tracing definition
we see that it immediately implies is
the key trader facing the namely we can
actually take a traceable kierra and
obtain traceable notions of other
symmetric cryptographic primitives if we
were to start with a water markable PRF
it turns out that this implication is
not true right because if we have a
water markable PRF the only guarantees
that provides is against adversaries
that can actually preserve the exact
input-output behavior of the
pseudo-random function this does not
allow us to construct a more remarkable
symmetric decryption devices and this I
think is a major limiting factor for
studying watermarking force to the
random functions under the previous
definitions and it says that it really
just gives us a standalone primitive we
cannot use the PRF as a building block
in the context of other primitives and
hope and the security properties
translate or generalize with the
traceable PRF it seems much more likely
that these kinds of generalizations are
possible because we're saying that any
adversary that can produce a circuit
that destroys or that distinguishes or
breaks security of the PRF it can be
traced so if you have an application
that's relying critically on a security
of a PRF now we have a tracing
definition that accommodates and
preserves those kinds same kinds of
security notions okay so now let me
summarize the main results that we show
and then I'll talk about constructions
and instantiations
so the first result that we show is that
assuming lwe there exists a single key
traceable PRF in a secret key setting so
when I say single key I just mean the
adversary can only see a single identity
so a single marquee we can consider more
general versions where the adversary can
actually see multiple marquees and still
is not able to break the tracing
security in this case we say that the
trace topo PRF is fully collusion
resistant so assuming lwe we cannot get
a fully collusion resistant traceable
PRF we can only get a single key version
and the scheme supports tracing in a
secret key setting but if we go up and
make stronger assumptions assuming IO
and injective one-way functions we can
get all of the properties we might want
we get full collusion resistance and we
also support public Tracy and the thing
that I think is interesting a very
notable about these constructions is
that the assumptions that we're using so
namely lwe and in particular what
primitive implied by all w/e this is a
notion of a private constraint ERF this
actually is the same assumptions as
those needed to realize water markable
PRF so even though we have significantly
strengthened the security definition of
a watermark of Akira via this notion of
a traceable chiara we did not need to
increase the Assumption complexity
needed to realize a traceable PRF
so everyone publicly tracing and while
folk eluding resistance in the water
marketing world the only constructions
are also only known from IO it was
objective what three functions
so in some sense we're still relying on
very similar building blocks but we're
able to use them in a way that gives us
much stronger security notions and in
this talk I'm going to focus this is a
lattice seminar I'm just going to focus
on the end of Yui based construction and
talk about how we build a single
untraceable your s essentially from
private constrained pseudo-random
functions okay
so the way that we're going to build a
traceable pseudo-random function is
we're going to go through an
intermediate notion and this
intermediate notion is something called
a private linear
constrained pseudo-random function and
for those of you who are familiar with
the trader tracing literature and their
landscape trader tracing this is the
exact analog about notion called primal
linear broadcast encryption introduced
by polonaise the high waters for
building trader tracing for public key
encryption so here again we're going to
look at this notion of a specialized to
the setting of a pseudo-random function
let me begin by introducing a dis
intermediate notion and then I will say
a few words about how we actually
realized is intermediate notion from the
other buoy assumption now let's begin
with a constrained PRF so I'm going to
parse this one adjective at a time so
let's start with a constrained
pseudo-random function but here we have
a PRF in a constraint here there is a
constraint algorithm and the constraint
algorithm takes in the key RF key and it
takes in a circuit C and it produces a
constrained key actually I'm just going
to forget about circuit constraints we
can talk about smaller or simpler
constrained families here it just
suffice it to think about circuits so
what does this constraint he allow us to
do well the constraint key will allow us
to evaluate the pseudo-random function
on all inputs that satisfy the
constraint so the constraint is a
predicate basically it's a function from
the domain of the PRF on 2:01 and here
we say that the constraint satisfies the
predicate if C of X evaluates to 1 so
the constraint t can be used to evaluate
everywhere where the constraint is
satisfied and if the constraint is not
satisfied then the actual PRF
evaluations at those points just still
look pseudo-random even given the
constraint G itself ok so I didn't
define a security notion here I just
have the correctness requirement but a
security requirement is that we have
pseudo randomness and all points in the
domain where the constraint is not
satisfied so we can evaluate where the
constraint is satisfied pseudo random
where the constraint is not satisfied so
in this setting we are all going to be
interested in linear constraints so what
is a linear constraint family so it's
going to be defined as follows first the
inputs in that the points in the domain
of the PRF some of that will have a
secret index or its
Craig associated with them and I'll talk
a little bit more about this tag later
on you can just assume that the domain
of the PRF can actually be split into
two pieces one is just an one maybe just
just like a let's say a bit string but
in addition there is a secret tag and a
secret tag is going to be a number
between 0 & 2 the DL so there's an L bit
tag associated with in some of the
inputs in the PRF how we use them I will
define a little bit in a little bit
later the second requirement is that the
constraint key now is associated with
another index your l denoted ID which is
also l bits long and it can be used to
evaluate on all inputs whose index key
is less than the ID so this is why we
say it's a linear constraint family
because essentially we have constraint
functions that can only be used to
evaluate on a subset of the domain is a
linear subset right it's all elements
that are smaller than the element in the
constraint key so I think it's a little
bit easier ah
before I say before I showed the
visualization of this let me say one
more thing so the privacy requirement
here is that the indexed and is
associated with the domain element is
actually hidden so easy tailed will come
together in the subsequent slides so if
it's fuzzy right now just wait a few
minutes and hopefully it will be clear
of clarified okay so just to make sure
things are clear let me just reiterate
so input points are associated with some
hidden index key constraint keys are
associating with an in with an identity
ID and it can be used to decrypt all
points whose indices are smaller than
the identity okay so this is why it's a
linear constraint family if you want to
visualize it on the line we can
visualize it like this right so here
this line represents the index
associated with domain elements of a
pseudo-random function if I have a key
for an indexed ID I can evaluate on all
points in the domain whose indices are
smaller than myself on all points whose
indices are bigger than my identity I
will not be able to evaluate okay so
this is what I mean
when I describe a
linear constraint family constraint ers
and finally you require one more
property which is that there exists a
sampling algorithm they allow us the
sample PRF inputs with the specific
index okay so there are zero to to to do
is the particular index they exist some
sampling algorithm that can allow me to
sample a domain element of the PRF with
a chosen index in some cases this could
be a secret key algorithm in other cases
this could be a public key of result so
I think there's a question so I'm at and
yes so I wanted to ask someone with a
constraint key can know whether he was
very weak ah good good yes so I will I
haven't defined the security properties
and what the constraint key and what you
should be able to learn or not learn I
given a constraint G so let me define
those the three security properties
first and then it was still not clear
please ask a question again okay good so
so what are what what should be hidden
from the holder of a constraint G so
there are three main security properties
that we will want so the first property
is that the domain element with index 0
so this in that 0 right here so notice
that every key should be able to
evaluate a domain element with index 0
all right because they're always going
to be less than or equal to every index
elements was a domain 0 and actually
indistinguishable from a uniform random
element over the entire domain okay
then that's the first property and I
should mention that all of these
properties should hold even given a
constraint G so I give you a constraint
key you can evaluate and elements where
the index 0 should always be evaluatable
and in fact not only other evaluatable
even given a constraint key you cannot
help that this is an element with index
0 it is indistinguishable from just
sounding a random element over the
entire domain the second property is the
identity hiding property which says that
if I have a domain element with index I
or index J
if you do not have a key that lands in
between indices I and J then you should
not be able to distinguish these two
domain elements so if you do have a key
that lands between I and J then this key
will allow you to evaluate on one of the
points but not the other point right you
could remember the constraint G allows
you to evaluate on all points that are
smaller than not valued so if you have a
key it lands in right in between two
elements then that might allow you to
distinguish but if you don't have such a
key you should not be able to
distinguish domain elements with those
two indices and finally the right last
requirement is that if I have a domain
element sample from the largest index so
it is 2 to the L this the PRF
evaluations at this point should be
pseudo-random even given any constraint
G because all of the constraints seized
will not be able to evaluate at this
particular point okay so the only hiding
properties that we require are hiding
properties on the indices on the domain
indices for the inputs to the PRF notice
that we do not require hiding properties
on a constraint key itself so if you
have a constraint key for let's say
identity ID you can read off ID from the
constraint G we do not require hiding or
not so does that answer the question
yes okay split excellent so the
constraint key does not hide the
identity but the indices should be
hidden in this precise manner so in the
C in element was index zero are
indistinguishable from uniform random
elements so is to do the exponential in
a security parameter or polynomial good
so that's a great question so it can be
exponential that will that means that we
can support an exponentially large
identity space it can also be polynomial
so everything I say also works is
actually agnostic to the size of the
domain for simplicity for the tracing
algorithm I will describe it will be
easier to think about it if the identity
space is polynomial but everything you
also extends naturally to the
Exponential's that thing I will say a
little few more words about that when I
define a tracing step okay all right so
how do we how do we if we have a private
linear constraint clear off with these
properties how can we trace okay so
let's take a look at the picture so the
assumption that we are given is that the
adversary it's going to give us a useful
distinguisher right so actually meant to
write distinguish it you're not decoder
decoder I guess is from a trader facing
language but here in that we're talking
about here at distinguishers so we have
a distinguisher D and it is able to
break weak pseudo randomness with some
noticeable advantage Epsilon how can we
use this to trace well let's take a look
suppose first that we sample and domain
element with index 0 here the normal
hiding requirement of our private linear
constraint ers says the following an
input was in that 0 is indistinguishable
from a uniform random element in the
domain of the PRF but now we have a
distinguisher that can break weeks to
the randomness with advantage epsilon so
weak pseudo randomness says that if I
sample a random element in the domain I
can distinguish that or if I have enough
of these elements I can distinguish them
with advantage Epsilon so if the
elements was index 0 are
indistinguishable from uniform random
elements over the photo main then the
advantage of the decoder when I give it
inputs with index 0 should be negative
we close to epsilon right because if the
decoder works on uniform over the full
domain and uniform over the element with
index 0 are indistinguishable from those
elements then a decoder that works here
must also work here ok so that's the
first first property second property
let's go to the other end of the extreme
so the pseudo randomness requirement on
a private linear constraint ERF family
says in a my sample an element whose
index is 2 to the L so the maximum
element in the range or in the identity
space either pseudo-random so the
decoder should have advantage that is
negligible so negligibly close to zero
right so pseudo randomness you're told
regardless of how many constraint is
left you can have as many in the
collision resistant circuit so and
that's something you can have
arbitrarily many constraint G's none of
them will be able to evaluate the PRF on
this to the DL index and therefore those
evaluations still look pseudo-random and
so the decoder will not be able to break
weeks pseudo randomness with elements
whose index is sample to be to the DL so
what do we have now
we have that in this space between 0 & 2
- DL on a one-handed decoder has
advantage epsilon has a noticeable
advantage I mean very other end of the
extreme the decoder has negligible
advantage so now suppose we do the
following we compare the distinguishing
advantage of the decoder at every point
along the way well then we know that
there must be a jump somewhere so they
went from something noticeable there's
something negligible so there must be a
jump in the distinguishing advantage
between some pair of elements in that
interval otherwise so here it's actually
conducive to think about that L to the
DL to be polynomial so for the
exponential case does it there's a more
sophisticated tracing algorithm that
will work but let's for a moment assume
that to the DL is polynomial in a
security parameter so now is logarithmic
in a security parameter then and we just
consider every consecutive index along
this interval and one of those intervals
there must be a large chunk right there
must be a noticeable jump you get
otherwise if this entry
sighs polynomial and every jump is
negligible we're not going to have a
noticeable drop from zero to the end of
the interval so where can those jumps up
here well the final property with this
as third property is identity hiding the
identity hiding property says the
following if I have an interval I and J
that does not contain the index that
does not contain a key that the
adversary query for the distinguishing
advantage can only differ by a
negligible amount the elements the
inputs to those elements are
indistinguishable from each other right
an input with index I is computationally
indistinguishable from a from a from an
element with index J so therefore the
distinguishing advantage cannot change a
pre-shop noticeably inside this interval
and so with these three properties we
can see that if there is a jump which
there must exist one because of the
bookends have a noticeable gap that jump
must appear at up interval that contains
the identity element right and if that
interval contains it then a tracing
algorithm will succeed so in the case
where the identity space no where L is
logarithmic and to the DL is polynomial
in a security parameter we can just do a
linear scan Elan dis entire interval we
stand for indices with index zero sample
in diseases index one comparative
distinguishing advantage and precede the
first place where we find a sharp drop
or a sharp change in the distinguishing
advantage we say that is the mark or
that is that compromise identity so all
of this actually also extends into the
case where CUDA DL is exponential here
we have to use the more sophisticated
tracing algorithm developed by in a work
Misha Buckley weeks and Landry there
they show how to also trace for an
exponentially large space I was
essentially reducing this tracing
problem to something called the Oracle
jump finding problem that same algorithm
also applies if we start with a private
linear constraint GRF so I don't have
time to describe it here but everything
I say does generalize to the setting
where we have an exponential identity
space here it's easier to think about
and see that this works even with the
polynomial identities
okay great so good so the implication is
there has to be a jump somewhere it has
stuff here at the at the compromise
identity this allows us to extract them
okay so we now identify this
intermediate primitive this notion of a
private linear constraint pseudo-random
function is the physis now to build this
primitive and we're going to show how to
build it from private can standard
private constraint erupts and then at
the very end of this talk I'm gonna give
a brief overview of how we actually
realized all of these ingredients from
lattice assumptions okay so let's begin
by starting with a standard vanilla
constraint pseudo-random function so we
know how to build constraints to do
random functions from lattices so
circuit constraint yes or no this is
Debra Kirksey if I couldn't do nothing
construction which I will overview give
an overview of at the very end of this
talk so let's just start there the let
domain of the PRF be the same as the
identity space right so now how do i
implement this linear constraint family
well the linear constraint family is
basically just a constraint for the
comparison function so the constraint
function has an IV hardwired inside it
the ID takes an index key because the
index is basically literally the domain
so of course this is no satisfied of
privacy requirement the index is public
right now but let's forget about that
for a moment let's just talk about
linear constraints right if we just want
a linear constraint well a circuit
constraint of course implements a linear
constraint family so you embed the ID as
part of the key it takes as input the
index and if the ID is less than the
index the constraint is not satisfied if
the ID is bigger than the index that
constraint is satisfied now this gives
us the first requirement linear
constraint PRF they should not be
surprising you know a constraint here
for circuits of course implies a
constraint PRF for a much simpler
functional family the problem of course
is that the indices for these domain
elements are completely public versus if
you look back to our tracing
construction we require some hiding
properties for these indices even given
constraint keys here even without the
constraint ease you can tell what those
indices are so if we want the high thing
well a natural thing to do in scrip goal
is we can encrypt the indices so now
suppose instead and we take the domain
of the PRF instead of having adjust the
it'd be identity space it will be the
space of ciphertext for some symmetric
encryption okay so take your favorite
symmetric encryption scheme the domain
of our PRF will be the set of spy cipher
texts for that encryption scheme so now
how do we do the constraint function
well a constraint function or the
constraint yeah the constraint function
that we want to handle will take as
input a domain element of the PRF what
is the domain element well it's a
ciphertext and basically a domain
element with index I will just be an
encryption of index I for that
particular under that particular
encryption scheme and this can be around
this should be a randomized encryption
scheme so there can be many many domain
elements that all have the same index
right basically Sampo some encryption
randomness encrypt the index that's your
domain element so how do we implement
this linear constraint family well it's
quite straightforward right
what we would do is we take the input
ciphertext you go hardwired the
decryption key for this symmetric
encryption key scheme inside the
constraint key so we hardwired the
decryption key and we simply decrypt the
ciphertext using the ID and then we do
the comparison exactly as before right
so this constraint key can be used to
decrypt input points now correspond to
all inputs that encrypt an index as
bigger than the ID so this exactly
implements the same linear constraint
family as before except instead of
having it on public indices we have
secret indices and we use a decryption
key to identify it if you there's still
a problem because if we have a standard
constrained key it leaks the decryption
key K and why why is this a problem
well the decryption key K is used to
decrypt the encrypted indices so
therefore if I give you let's say in a
PRF domain element with index I
well that domain element will be an
encryption of I if my constraint key
leaks the decryption key well then you
actually
recovery index I and this is problematic
so again this is not a not a difficult
problem to fix all we need is a
something called a private constraint
PRF so here there's a little bit of
overloading of notation or terminology
when I say a private constraint your F I
mean that the constraint here FG because
right so it hides the constraint
description so in particular it hides
the decryption you see in a private
linear constraint here as the privacy
property is privacy for the index
associated with domain elements but
using a private constraint PRF we can
actually complete this picture so if we
use a private constraint clear us in
conjunction with a symmetric encryption
scheme we obtain a private linear
constraint or F as follows so why do
these properties now hold so normal
hiding says that if I encrypt to index 0
or domain element with index 0 they
should be indistinguishable from random
domain elements this is ok as long as
the encryption scheme has pseudo-random
cipher text right then the encryption of
any element will look like a uniform
random string over the entire ciphertext
space if the encryption scheme has
pseudo-random cipher texts and as long
as the constraint he hides the symmetric
key or the secret key for the encryption
scheme and then we can appear the pseudo
randomness of the encryption scheme to
argue more more hiding
fried enemy hiding this follows just
directly from like the semantic security
of the underlying encryption scheme so
the main elements with index I and J
well why are they indistinguishable well
the elements correspond to the
encryption of I and the encryption of J
if these encryption scheme is
semantically secure and the constraint
he has a secret key we can appear a
semantic security of the underlying
encryption scheme thirdly this property
and finally pseudo randomness why are
the PRF evaluations our input was the
maximum index pseudo-random this exactly
followed by constraint security of the
constraint PRF namely if the message
space of the encryption scheme is
between 0 & 2 to the L minus 1 then when
we decrypt we will never produce an
element that's bigger than to the deal
so then if the underlying constraint
here
family satisfies constraint security
namely the PRF evaluations at inputs not
satisfied by the constraint are
pseudo-random then we get a pseudo
randomness as well for our private
linear constraint we're a family so to
summarize how do we construct to
constrain PRF we basically showed us
starting from a private constraint Kirra
in any symmetric encryption scheme
so in fact private constraint here is
anti long wave functions which implies
symmetric encryption so technically we
just need five FS right PRF we get a
private linear constraint PRF with where
we have a secret sampling procedure and
this gives us a traceable pseudo-random
function with secret tracing so the
secrets sampling is because you need
knowledge of the encryption key in order
to sample and you also need to be able
to sample PRF evaluations which require
information about the secret key of the
PRF so starting from the lwe assumption
we can realize single key private
constraint ers which propagates through
our generic transformation and gives us
single key traceable PRF this is exactly
the same building blocks that we require
for building single key watermark of all
PRF
so we just take a look at this box right
here so lwe going to single key private
constraint yes this goes to water
markable PRF higher previous works in
this work we show that it also suffices
to give us traceable prfs but now
satisfying a much much stronger notion
of security compared to the previous
constructions if we want a public
tracing it turns out that this does
require some additional tools and the
main difficulty is that in order in a
public trading scheme we need to be able
to sample PRF evaluations so we need to
be able to sample both PRF inputs as
well as the outputs because remember the
tracing algorithm has oracle access to a
distinguisher and it is the input to the
distinguisher needs to be inputs and
output pairs for them from the PRF
family and so it's not just a matter of
fact of replacing the symmetric
encryption schemes here with a public
key encryption scheme that doesn't work
because that well duh steps that solves
the problem of being
want to sample the inputs it does not
give us a way to sample the outputs and
in order to do this the way that we
showed in our work if we can do it from
indistinguishability of the station
together with injective one-way
functions we basically publish an
obfuscated program it has the PRF key
hardwired incited that allows us to
publicly sample inputs and output pairs
from the PRF family if we just use
private constrains ahrefs is not clear
how to realize this so realizing public
tracing from standard assumptions or
realizing it without going through i/o
is an open problem yeah and this is also
the case in the setting of watermarking
one of the advantages of the i/o
construction is that it also gives us
for collusion resistance notice here
that we only get single T David yeah
yeah she's coming
one quick remark if you like so let's
say you didn't want to use i/o you only
okay with learning with errors it's kind
of interesting at least to me that you
know you normally think of prfs is a
great in the normal world there's a
great building block for building up
symmetric key crypto and all this stuff
but it's here and I guess we got this
feedback you know to that like in the
tracing world we can only do single key
whereas if we didn't start with PRF so
we just built you know from previous
work we just built in traceable
encryption directly we can do better I
mean it almost seems like there is a
message of like maybe this isn't the
right building maybe you should just
build each primitive tracing
individually and not go through the PRF
route right right now that's a great
point and I think that's kind of
highlights some of the interesting
aspects in the tracing rope so I get a
standard classic symmetric encryption
you have PRF you can get everything but
once we want like a traceable analog of
these primitives that same intuition
doesn't seem to translate because a
traceable PRF sure implies a traceable
encryption scheme but we don't know how
to build a place of a PRF with folk
illusion resistance versus we do have
great constructions a traceable
encryption with full collusion
resistance so that might suggest that
when we look at the crazier tracing for
specific primitives it might actually be
more reason
as friend suggests to actually target
the actual primitives that we want
rather than goes through the underlying
just try and do it for a building block
of course if we now are able to build a
let's say a fully collision resistant
range to Pokhara we do recover those
same implications but that seems like a
much harder problem than just targeting
the primitives directly okay so just to
summarize this first part of the talk so
the main motivation that inspired us and
the main message but I want you to take
away from here is that the existing
definitions of software watermarking
especially in the context of
cryptographic functionalities does not
offer us very strong security because it
imposes very significant restrictions on
the adversaries capability and the way
that we address that in this work is by
reintroducing this new notion of a
traceable PRF with a much stronger
notion of unremovable ax T which
basically says that if the adversary can
construct a program that allows us to
break security of the underlying
cryptographic primitive mainly breaking
pseudo randomness then such a program
must preserve the watermark independent
of whether the program preserves
input-output behavior and so on
and I think the more general takeaway is
is that when we start studying these
notions of trader tracing or
watermarking for these different kinds
of functionalities is we should actually
think more broadly about the security of
our out yes sorry we just think more
broadly about our security notions then
most natural one of sort of tying
together functionality preserving to
exact input-output preservation this may
actually not be the most reasonable or
the most lorna most useful security
notion and just because it might open us
up to new adversarial strategies that
were not that are not captured by
existing models so the most natural
notion and the prevailing notions that
has been considered as studied
previously may not be the best
definitions and I think there isn't
there's a lot of value in revisiting
some of those definitional foundations
in order to figure out and identify what
is the most reasonable or the most
useful definition for studying and
analyzing
these kinds of primitives and we sort of
have made some progress on that in this
case watermarking TRS by going to this
traceable PRF round and in terms of the
construction side the main construction
the main intermediate primitive that we
rely on is this notion of a private
linear constraint PRF and we showed that
starting from the yoga UE assumption we
can go all the way to a single -
traceable PRF so in this talk I sort of
show the last where the two arrows in
the middle going from private
constraints to linear constraint RS and
then private linear constraint here has
two traceable CRFs and all of those
details are provided in that print so
any questions yeah so in a remaining
time I have left I'm going to give you
an overview of the first half of this
transformation so how do we actually
build by the constraint here that's from
malcolm ue this will be based on
previous works by speaking of the node
as well as I speak I brought some
another context so any questions about
the feasible clear after all before I go
into the more algebraic site and show
how we actually construct these gifts
from lattices okay so we have not let me
just hurry up so this will be the last
part of the talk since this is a lattice
seminar after all so how do we actually
build a pseudo-random functions or a
constraint here from lattices well let's
start from first principles or start
directly of how to build a PRF for a lot
of space assumptions so just to recall
the learning with errors assumption says
if you have a uniform random matrix a
and you take a noisy linear combination
of the rows of a and that looks
uniformly random and then so this
assumption by itself does not may not
seem the most conducive to constructing
a pseudo-random function
sure it has a pseudo randomness flavor
in the sense that you have something
that's indistinguishable from random but
there's something depends on this
moister right and this makes it more
challenging to construct a pseudo-random
function because pseudo-random functions
are deterministic objects so when
constructing pseudo-random functions
from lattice based assumptions
Elementary placards are awesome they
show they basically show that we can
actually replace this error with a
deterministic rounding step and then we
can base security on something called
the learning with rounding assumption
which for certain choices of parameters
P and - it actually reduces to lwb so
the learning with the rounding
assumption basically says that instead
of taking the inner product between the
secret of the bue secret s and the
matrix a and then adding noise we're
instead going to round down to a much
smaller modulus key so we're going to
scale by the value P over Q over the
rationals round to the nearest integer
and that will be our volume so the noise
is placed by deterministic rounding so
once we have done this it actually seems
much more straightforward how we can
realize a pseudo-random function so let
me give now the general group the
general blueprint for constructing a lot
of space pseudo-random function so most
of the existing constructions will work
as follows there will be a collection of
public parameters and these will just be
public random matrices a1 up to Al and
the key rft will be an lwe secret s and
in order to evaluate well we want
something that looks like this
and the way that we're going to do so is
the following to evaluate at a point X
we're gonna take our public parameters
and our X and there will be some
procedure some public procedure of
taking X and the public parameters and
deriving from them a matrix a sub X and
then a PRF evaluation with the PRPs will
just be s transpose times de round it
down so this looks very much like an out
of you our instance and the question in
constructing these lattice based PRF is
what is the procedure that we use for
this particular derivation how do we
derive a matrix a sub X from the public
parameters together with us and
different works and different
constructions with different properties
will describe a numerous ways of doing
so here I will just describe one
particular
mtrs and then private constraint ers now
before we do that we need to do one more
we need one more building block which is
the G we have to come back to the GSW
fully homomorphic encryption so which
entry is the high waters classic Shu
scheme and it has the homomorphic
operations and the homomorphic
properties that we need for our main
constructions so I think protect leave a
great talk at the previous workshop
going over the GSW homomorphisms I fear
I will just give a very brief reminder
so in the GSW fhe scheme the public G is
just that lwe matrix a so namely the
columns of a are lwe samples the secret
key is essentially the lwe secret and
then you can can make one at the end the
invariant and the main property that we
will want is that s transpose times a as
I define it here is very small it's just
the error term or approximately zero
vector so now a ciphertext for an input
X in the GSW scheme it's just going to
be a times R plus X times G the
important thing is that r is a random
short matrix G here's the gadget matrix
and if the cipher text had this
particular form decryption succeeds in
the in the standard manner mainly you
take the inner product between a out the
VV secret and the ciphertext you use the
fact that s transpose times the public
key
vanishes and you essentially recover x
times s transpose times the gadget and
now we know that LW e with respect to
the public data matrix because it has a
public trapdoor it's easy we can
actually recover X in fact G here has
large entries so you can actually just
recover X by relative but again those
details are not super important and
let's just look at the algebraic
structure of the DFA GC so the second
ingredient that we need are the
homomorphic properties of this
encryption scheme so in the first column
morphism so these are the two equations
that we saw from the lattice workshops a
few weeks back for the first homo more
festive homomorphisms is the public
homomorphisms so given a collection of g
SW cipher texts
there is a way to compute a GSW
ciphertext for a new function f of X
right namely let's say I have the
encryptions of X 1 up to X L I can
there's a public algorithm that takes an
D ciphertexts and the function f and
produces a sub F which is essentially a
GSW encryption of the value f of X ok so
there's a public algorithm that does not
depend on X but this is why I call it
the input independent evaluation of
result because in some sense
I will view this these years of your
cypher text as encoding of the bits of X
but now there's a public algorithm and
without knowledge of the encoding sub X
allows me to compute a function of X in
a public matter so it allows me to
derive this matrix based of s and not
only is this a holomorphic operation
homomorphic in the inputs in the encoded
values it is also ho a morphic in the
randomness in the encryption randomness
in a very precise form namely the new
encryption randomness can actually be
expressed as a short linear combination
of the original encryption method this
and here this is this randomness
evaluation or randomness homomorphism
will be covered by this matrix H sub F
of X ok so if we look at this equation
so this is the correctness requirement
on a GSW encryption scheme namely when I
compute when I follow morphic we
evaluate on these ciphertext I obtain an
encryption of f of X and with randomness
our sub F X I can now take this
randomness homomorphism and essentially
rearrange the equation a little bit and
notice and then what I will get back is
something that looks like this so this
second equation here what would be what
I call the input independent evaluation
so it's very easy to see how to get this
you just left multiply by a and then you
use the invariant for a GSW ciphertexts
all right so basically these two
equations are the main equations that we
will rely on when we construct our
lattice based PRS and the important
thing to note here that these two
equations essentially both provide us a
way to compute a column matrix a sub F
right
here if I know a 1-up to Al and the
description of the function s I can
compute a CF here if I have essentially
an encoding of the bits of X and I know
this function H where I know this matrix
H which is a function of the public
matrices F and the input X that is y is
input dependant I can now compute a sub
F minus this additional term f of X
times G ok so these are the two main
equations that we will use to help us
build a constrained PRF this also gives
us things like attribute based
encryption it can also be used to get
how a morphic signatures and so on all
right so let's now look at the Parker
scheme I can connive in construction of
a lattice based constraint pseudo-random
function the domain of a PRF in this
case will just be a rope its string and
we're going to use a universal circuit
as part of our construction so here I'm
going to define a universal circuit it
has an input X hardwired inside it it
takes in as input a description of a
function f and it computes f of X so
let's say the description length of the
circuit here is exactly L then the
public parameters of my lattice based
constraints here F will just be matrices
a1 update L these will be used to encode
the bits of the function f the pub here
of t would just be an lwe secret a PRF
evaluation will be using that public
comment morphism that I described
earlier you will take a 1 up to Al and
the input X and we're going to evaluate
the function u sub X so the universal
circuit was X hardwired inside it the
PRF evaluation will be the matrix
associated with the function u sub X ok
this is a function it depends on the
input the function that we're going to
evaluate is the universal circuit
evaluation and a PRF evaluation then
we'll just be defined as the inner
product between the lwe secret namely
the PR secret master secret
times this matrix a step UX so the way
that we're going to derive this matrix
that we're going to multiply by is
exactly using the GS w homomorphic
operation so using the input independent
a homomorphism
so notice that if you know X and you
know the secret you can complete this
quantity how do we constrain this
function well here we're going to try
and build something it looks like the
input independent home that's right
then you lies on the input dependent
evaluation procedure right so before we
show that there are two ways of
computing this quantity a sub Q of X 1
is using a public evaluation the other
one will be using the input dependent or
secret or private evaluation mechanism
so just a note for convention I'm
actually going to invert the convention
this is pretty standard at lattices
where a lot of space constraint your
apps we will say that the constraint is
satisfied is f of X equals 0 so before I
was saying that the constraint is
satisfied is C of X evaluates to 1 now I
will say the constraint is satisfied if
f of X evaluates to 0 the reason for
this will become clear very soon so we
can evaluate on all point X in the
domain where f of X equals 0 so the
constraint key for a function f
essentially consists of an encoding of
an lwe encoding of the function f ok
so the way now we encode is we just take
the bits of the function f and we
compute the standard g SW encoding so a
1 minus f 1 times G and so on and we're
going to multiply by the other by that
is decreasing so why is this useful
let's see how we can try to use this to
evaluate so what we can do is we want to
get something of the form s times a
where a depends on use of X so the way
that we can do that if we have an
encoding is we can multiply by the
matrix H for this function U of X with
the function f so here we know the
function f and we know the description
of U sub X which we know because we're
evaluating at the function X we can just
multiply by this evaluation matrix is
input dependent evaluation matrix and by
the properties that I just outlined on
the previous slide this product a 1
minus F 1 G this encoding multiplied by
the H matrix this gives us exactly a sub
u of X minus the function f minus write
the function use of X evaluated on F are
used so that's the valuation on that is
exactly as Max and so we get f of X
times G and now this is a very very nice
observation if f of X equals zero notice
both of here we use the fact that H that
H is also short so Eric hang something
short is so small so this basically is
approximately the same this is
approximately zero so now if f of X
equals zero now this term vanishes and
we get exactly s transpose as a sub G of
X and notice that if the error is small
then it disappears I mean when we when
we round down so when we reduce modulo P
and these T these two elements actually
align okay so this gives us a way to
evaluate the PRF at using the constraint
G we just use the input dependent
evaluation procedure okay so to argue
pseudo randomness it turns out that we
have to do a little bit more work we
want to multiply by another fixed matrix
this ensures that we can execute for
pseudo randomness of the construction
I'm not going to go into the details
here but basically the core algebraic
requirements are all captured about what
I have written here and there's a few
additional details that we have to
introduce in order to argue security
formally but I think for the general
intuition those will not be super
essential okay but there is a problem
yeah because if if our goal is to build
a private constraint here F and the
reason is that in order to compute this
evaluation matrix H here this is a
function that depends on the public
parameters it depends on F and it
depends on its like it depends on the
public parameters it depends on the
input X and it also depends on F the
constraint function right in order to
construct this matrix we need to know
the constraint and so this does not give
us privacy for the constraint so the
idea in the work brickowski as a
bereaved a Quinta nothing and we is
instead of publishing the constraint in
the clear what we're going to do is
we're going to encrypt the function f
using an S AG ski and instead of
evaluating use of X directly we're going
to halt
perfectly evaluate the universal circuit
so let's just see what that looks like
first and then we'll see how to complete
the construction and that will conclude
the talk so instead of publishing Essen
and clear what we're going to do is
we're going to encrypt F using an fhe
scheme and now we can just publish the
encryption of s in the clear the
security of the fhe scheme will allow us
to hide the function f so here suppose
that the bit lengths of the cipher text
that encrypts s is L we will now define
the holomorphic evaluation function as
simply uses the homomorphic li evaluates
the universal circuit on the encrypted
function f and this will produce an
encryption of f of X so technically this
function right here does not output a
bit is function right here actually
outputs a ciphertext I'll talk a little
bit about how we avoid that issue that
would not be an issue for us ok so now
let's just go through the previous
constraint here as construction and just
replace the function f with this
encryption which is cipher text well
weep so ok so we can do everything
exactly as before the constraint G will
now just be an encoding of the encrypted
function f and a constrained evaluation
we can again just do exactly as before
we're going to multiply I'm a new
evaluation function which is a function
of the holomorphic evaluation of X as
well as a ciphertext and encrypts F so
here disc is now this only depends on
public operations this is not require
knowledge of F as long as f hat hides F
and if we just go through all of the
previous steps by the correctness of the
g SW homomorphisms the sort of the
second evaluation relation the input
dependent evaluation when we compute
this quantity right here we basically
get in there the Bui instance where we
have s transpose times a with respect to
the holomorphic evaluation function this
is good but instead of getting f of X
times G we now get the output of the
homomorphic computation on G and this is
problematic for two reasons one as ages
it's not a bit so the things I write
here doesn't quite parse
but we can fix the first this part by
just saying that this computes one bit
of other ciphertext and then you just
complete computer one bit at a time so
let's let's ignore that issue the bigger
issue is that this holomorphic li
computed quantity is an encryption of f
of X it is not equal to f of X and the
correctness requirement the reason that
the algebra worked out before is that we
said that if the constraint is satisfied
f of X equals 0 and this term vanishes
but if you have an encryption of f of X
we have an encryption of 0 encryption of
0 is not 0 so it's not going to vanish
so we need a different idea to fix this
problem so let me first address the
issue that this is not a bit it turns
out that we can actually generalize the
GSW holo morphisms to matrix valued
functions so here we have the standard
GSW homomorphisms input input
independent evaluation input dependent
evaluation that evaluates any binary
value function here is actually
straightforward to extend this to matrix
valued functions where we have a
function f that outputs a matrix x
associated with that and instead of
computing f of X times G we compute a
sub F minus a matrix x times F I'm not
going to go into detail of how to do
this it turns out that you can just use
the first set of equations compute
everything bit by bit and then just sum
them together using properties of the
gadget matrix so in the interest of time
I won't go into details there
essentially the takeaway I want you to
get is that the GSW homomorphism is very
naturally generalized to matrix valued
functions it's just it's it's just
fairly standard algebra there ok so the
second and a more challenging problem
that we needed to fix is that instead of
instead of evaluating to f of X the
constrained evaluation is giving me a
holomorphic evaluation of FX so I end up
with an encryption of f of X rather than
f of X itself so here we're going to use
one more property we're not going to use
any standard
fhe scheme or any vanilla fhu scheme
we're going to use a very particular fhe
scheme it has a lot of the same
algebraic structure as when we're using
to encode and the function itself which
naturally will be the GSW
to homomorphic encryption scheme so
notice at energy SW homomorphic
encryption scheme the decryption
algorithm is just taking an inner
product between s and the ciphertext and
this inner product decryption procedure
has the following property if we compute
inner product with the secret key and
the matrix we end up with X of the
plaintext value times s transpose times
G plus some error term Vienna was an
encoding of X of the encoding of X in
the clear plus Center so we will use
this property to help us address the
decryption challenge okay so let's come
back to that to the constraint PRS
construction where we have replaced the
function with you s AG encryption of the
function replace evaluation with
holomorphic evaluation the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
ensure that when we perform this how a
morphic evaluation the output will
actually be a single GSW ciphertext so
this will not be any fhe ciphertext so
don't put you can't put any other fa
cheese there now we're just going to
look at the g SW ciphertext g SW scheme
in particular and we're going to define
this how a morphic computation to output
the actual g SW ciphertext so now this
does not quite solve the problem of
constrained evaluation quite yet but the
second thing and we will observe and a
really great insight in a workup
rehearse key at all is that if we use
the same secret key s here as both the
PRF secret key but not only in the Parc
cookie but also the secret key for this
g SW encryption scheme so when we
encrypt and this is the g SW encryption
of the function f where the secret key
is actually the same secret as our PRF
construction well it then this use of X
here and I constructed in the
holomorphic evaluated ciphertext to the
g SW ciphertext and encrypts f of X but
it is a GSW ciphertext and encrypts f of
X well the property of the g SW
encryption scheme says that if I take
the inner product between the secret key
and the ciphertext I'm going to get an
encode
the actual plaintext value what does
that encoding look like well as f of X
and s transpose G plus some error so we
just replace s transpose times this GSW
ciphertext here where's the GS the new
decryption relation lo and behold we did
exactly what we wanted from the original
recursive vacuum to nothing constraint
PRS construction namely we get s
transpose times the matrix that this is
the real PRF evaluation times f of x
times s transpose G once again if f of X
equals 0 this term vanishes and we
recover the real PRF evaluation so some
streets are again needed to argue
security we need to multiply by an
additional matrix here
can we randomized things and ensure
constraint security there's also a
somewhat delicate argument to make sure
that we can reuse the secret key for the
PRF and for the religiosity metric risky
so our refer to their paper for the full
details there but I hope this gives you
a flavor for how we construct private
constraint PRS from assumptions so just
to summarize the second part of the top
everything here was predicated on two
main equations as usual for a lot of
these these modern lattice constructions
derived from the GSW slash permeate all
follow morphisms the first equation is
the input independent independent
evaluation this is the GSW homomorphism
and then there's an input dependent
evaluation that allows us to homomorphic
Li compute functions on encoded values
in this in if we do a TS w / they'll be
TQ + through this lens
well then the first equation gives us
PRF evaluation the second equation gives
us constrained evaluation and to argue
to get a private constraint PRS
so here by itself this combined with
universal circuits this gives you a
single key lattice based constraint
pyaara to get privacy the two main ideas
is we first encrypt the constraint using
the GSW fhe scheme and then we use it's
very very clever dual use idea where the
same lwe secret if you for both the PRF
secret key as well as the fhe secret key
and then that will actually allow us to
get exactly the right out rubric
structure can recover the constraint PRF
or the constrained evaluations procedure
of previous constraint PRS and hence
give us the private constraint PRS from
standard lattice assumptions and with
that I'll conclude so hopefully that
gives you a flavor for how we build
private constraint PRS and give them
five a constraint
yes you can instantiate our framework in
the first part of this talk and actually
build a traceable PRF that gives you
very strong properties against
adversaries that might try to break the
clear
Thanks all right thank you David for the
wonderful dog gasps look hello yeah so
yeah if people have any questions now
feel free to ask questions in the chat
or just unmute yourself
maybe I'll just stop the recording for
now